[موسيقى]
طاب مساؤكم ضربات ايرانيه جديده ضد
مجموعات من المعارضه الكرديه الايرانيه في
كردستان العراق هذه ليست المره الاولى
ضربات مماثله تمت قبل اسبوع نهايه سبتمبر
كذلك تركيا ايضا ضربت في شمال
سوريا واستهدفت قواعد لحزب العمال
الكردستاني ومسلحي وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه السوريه التي تعتبرها تركيا جناحا
لحزب العمال
الكردستانيين يحاول فهم ما يحدث في
المناطق الكرديه هناك معي هنا في الاسود
والكاتب السياسيه الاستاذ كرزون حميد اهلا
وسهلا
سيكون معي من بغداد الاستاذ بسام القزويني
وهو الباحث في الشؤون السياسيه والامنيه
من اسطنبول معي كذلك الباحث في العلاقات
الدوليه الاستاذ محمود علوش
ومن طهران هاتفيه الكاتب السياسي الاستاذ
سعيد شاوردي اهلا وسهلا بكم
جميعا البدايه
معك الاستاذ كرزون
يعني لمن لم يفهم ما يحدث في المناطق
الكرديه الان من يعني ضربات ايرانيه
وتركيا هل تشرح لنا الموضوع بايجاز
قبل الضربات الايرانيه والتركيه على مناطق
اقليم كردستان او في شمال شرق سوريا او ما
نقل الرشاقه لازم ندرس الوضع السياسي
الداخلي للبلدين المهاجمين ان هم تركيا
وايران منذ شهرين ستدخل شهرها الثالث
شعبيه
اوراق لخروج من هذه الازمه السياسيه التي
يمر بها احتجاجات شعبيه شاب تشابهه
لاحتجاجات 1979 اثناء السقوط الشرق ما تمر
تركيا بعكس ايران لا توجد احتجاجات ولكن
حكومه حزب العداله والتنميه تمر في ازمه
السياسيه الشعبيه متدنيه تبحث عن مخرج
تبحث عن
طوق النجاه من هذه العمليات تبحث عن شيء
يله الشعب شيء ان يكون له هو المسيطر
الوحيد على العمليه السياسيه التاليه يعني
انا
اقتبس كلام
الزعيم المعارضه التركيه كماليك الجدار
اوغلو قبل سته اشهر وبالذات في الشهر مايو
2022 تحدث عن اوراق الرئيس التركي عبد
الله
رجب طيب اردوغان عن اسباب او الخطط
المستقبليه لخلط الاوراق
للاستحام او بقاء في السلطه لمده اكثر قال
فيها انه هناك خطط لبلبه العارمه في
البلاد
والتعزيم الوضع السياسي والامني
او اجتياح اخر الاراضي السوريه ضد الاكراد
من اجل بقاء في السلطه وجذب الاصوات
القوميين او تغيير الوضع السياسي الموجود
وهذه عمليات تدار من قبل شركه اسمها شركه
سادات للاستشارات الامنيه التي كانت تقدم
استشارات امنيه وسياسيه وعسكريه للرئيس
التركي
عن كثير من الامور ان تركيا تركيا كلما
تمر في ازمه السياسيه
في وضع غير صالحه تبحث عن الحرب في سوريا
الشمال السوري تتهم الاكراد بالارهاب تتهم
الاكراك
تتحدث
سوريا
صالح الدوله الاخرى تركيا تريد ان تسيطر
على مناطق كرديه ذات ثروات طبيعيه كبيره
نعلم جيده ان الستين من الثروات الطبيعيه
موجوده في الاراضي الكرديه التي تسيطر
عليها وحده وحده حمايه الكرديه كما حالتي
اقليم كردستان
وايران وايران تريد تبحث عن جزء او حصه من
هذه يعني ايران وتركيا
انها تكون بالتوازي هناك التوافق بينهما
نعم هناك اكيد هناك اكيد
هو المكونه الكردي في المنطقه يعني امريكا
تركيا قبل قصف الشمال العراق او اقليم
الكردستاني
والشمال الشرق سوريا حذرت القنصليه
الامريكيه في اربيل حضرت ورعاها طيب السفر
الى اقليم كردستان همم الاستاذ محمود علوش
من اسطنبول عن هذا التنسيق الايراني
التركي هل تؤمن به استاذ محمود
بدايه مساء الخير لا شك انه
الهاجس من المشروع الانفصالي الكردي في
العراق على وجه التحديد يشكل قاسم مشترك
بالنسبه
لايران وتركيا بشكل رئيسي لكن هناك بالطبع
خلافات كبيره بين البلدين دبا لانه
الخلافات بين تركيا وايران موجوده حتى
اساسا في الملف الكوردي فيما يتعلق بسوريا
ااا ايران يعني
تقدم نفسها على انها معارضه تماما لاي خطه
لعمليه عسكريه تركيا في شمال السوري وهي
تنظر الى ان اي تقدم في النفوذ التركي في
شمال سوريا سيكون على حسابها من الواضح
انه المساله الكرديه في شمال سوريا هي
نقطه خلاف ايضا بين الجانبين الايراني
والتركي ايضا في شمال العراق رغم يعني همم
ال- همم الان المسرح المشتركه في تحجيم
المشروع الانفصالي الكردي ومقاتلي حزب
العمال الكردستاني من جا وايضا للجماعات
المحسوبه عليه الا ان هناك تنافس بين
انقره وطهران فيما يتعلق بالحاله الكرديه
في شمع العراق لا اعتقد بانه هناك تناغم
بالكامل همم نحن نشهد تناغم عندما تصل
الامور الى لحظه مفصليه بالنسبه للجانبين
سيما كما شاهدنا في خلال فتره استفتاء همم
استقلال اقليم كردستان العراق كان هناك
تناغم تركي ايراني الى حد كبير لكن فيما
بعد ذلك عادت الخلافات والتنافس بين
البلدين من جديد يظهر همم تركيا تدعم جناح
كردي حزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي الكردستان
الى ان تدعم حزب الاتحاد الوطني لكردستاني
وبالتالي كل طرف يعني لديه مصالح وهمم
اهداف خاصه فيما يتعلق بالحلال الكرديه
لكن لا شك انه في العناوين الكبيره عندما
تصل الحاله المسلحه الكرديه الى تهديد لكل
من الجانبين التركي والايراني بطبيعه
الحال نشهد التناغم وتنسيق لكن فيما يتعلق
بهذه العمليه على وجه دي لا اعتقد بانه
هناك تنسيق ربما ال- ال- الوضع الداخلي
الذي تمر به ايران بالاضافه الى الوضع
الامني ايضا بالنسبه لتركيا وايضا العامل
الداخلي بطبيعه الحال تفضل به الضيف هو
موجود لكن لا اوافق بانه هو همم دافع او
محرك رئيسي للعمليات العسكريه التركيه
حاليا في شمال العراق همم شمال سوريا
اعتقد انه يلعب دور في هذا التناغم الغير
مقصود والغير متعمد بتقديره بين الجانبين
التركي والايراني في العمليه العسكريه
بغداد الاستاذ بسام القزويني لماذا لم
نسمع احتجاجا همم يعني بصوت عالي من ال-
من الطرف العراقي على ما يحدث همم على ارض
عراقيه
تحيه طيبه يا استاذ عادل ضيوفك الكرام
بالتاكيد ما يجري في الشمال العراق
والشمال سوريا هو لا اقول انه توافق قد
يكون هو توافق صامت بين تركيا وايران لكن
اعتقد فيها ان ال معادله الاوضح ان هنالك
من فعل كل من انقره وطهران اين اتدخل
التركي
ويكون هنالك الصمت في الداخل العراقي
والصمت من المجتمع الدولي يتيح لايران
التدخل المماثل وايضا العمليه العكسيه فان
التدخل الايراني سيعطي لتركيا ايضا حزمه
اضافيه لغرض الدخول اكثر الى الاراضي
العراقيه اعتقد في ان هذا
يشكل نظاما حيويا لكل من انقر التي يبحث
اردوغان فيها عن رئاسه او روايه الثالثه
في الانتخابات القادمه في انعام 20 23
وكذلك لايران الباحث عن
اطفاء الشعله الداخليه وايضا لا ننسى في
ان تبحث عن تاطير حزامها الذهبي كما تسميه
الذي يبدا بحدودها من افغانستان مرورا
بالعراق وسوريا وصولا الى البحر المتوسط
في لبنان بالتالي هذه المعادله تعطي ربما
هنالك تؤثر على الداخل العراقي هنالك ربما
بعض الجماعات القريبه من ايران التي قد
تكون مرحبا غير معلنه عن ذلك في ان هناك
تدخل ايراني وترفض التدخل التركي وايضا
هنالك ان تكون احزاب ترحب بالتدخل التركي
وترفض التدخل الايراني لكن مصلحه العراق
في هذه المعادله لا تنتهي بالادانات اي ان
الا اذانات دي العراق المستمره ان كان على
مستوى الاحتجاج ومذكرات الاحتجاجات التي
قدمت والشكوى في مجلس الامن دائما تجديد
دفعا حتى اللحظه العراق يحتاج الى بناء
اليات يبحث عن النقاط التي ممكن منها يثمر
اا النتائج واعتقد في ان هنالك ربما ثلاثه
مسارات يمكن للعراق المضي بها اولا العراق
لديه اتفاق مع النيتو في مجال الاستشاره
والتدريب وبالتالي يمكن له البحث في هذه
العلاقه وتطويرها في ان يضمن النقطه ثالثه
وهي اا حفظ سياده العراق من دول نيتويه
تتدخل في الاراضي العراقيه ويعني تركيا اي
يضغط على النيتول لغرض ايقاف التدخل
التركي هذه محاوله تسليج الاولى ايضا
للعراقي يمكن له تفعيل قرار مجلس الامن
1770 الذي اقر في العام 2007 والذي دعى
فيه الى تقديم الدعم والمشوره في حل مساله
الحدود الداخليه في المناطق المتنازع
عليها وكما اكد هذا القرار على استقلال
وسياده وحدات وسلامه اراضي العراق اي ان
هذا القرار الموجود حاليا لدى الحكومه
العراقيه ولذا البرلمان العراقي يمكن
للعراق تفعيل هذا القرار لانه اتى على
سلامه اراضي العراق ليكون بدايه يعني يكون
هناك قرار اممي اخر يوقف التدخل الايراني
التدخل التركي لكن هذا يحتاج الى تنسيق
عالم بين اربيل وبغداد وبالتحديد اربيل
الى طهران معك الاستاذ سعيد جاء وردي هل
همم هل هناك حديث في ايران عن تنسيق
ايراني همم تركيا في مثل هذه المسائل
استاذ سعيد هل سمعت السؤال
قد نعود الى الاستاذ سعيد شاوردي لاحقا
اعود الى
عوده
يعني المشكله العراق انه مشكله العراق
صامت متكلم او متكلم الصامت
في تطوير القدرات الامنيه
نتذكر انه 2008 في رئاسه جورج بوش الابن
مع رئيس الوزراء الاسباق نور المالكي حصل
اتفاقيه استراتيجيه بين العراق وولايات
المتحده ومن ضمنها كانت انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه من العراق وكانت 2008 بدايه
الاتفاق الاستراتيجي اي امريكا مسؤول عن
حمايه والسياده العراق من اي تهديد امني
ان امريكا متواطئه بجزء ما في هذه
العمليات
ان كانت على علم او كانت موافقه وغير
موافقه نعلم انه الرئيس التركي قبل اشهر
هدد باجتياح اخر لاراضي السوريه
فرفض من قبل روسيا ومن الولايات المتحده
بالذات
ومن ايران ايضا يعني يمكن للعراق ان يفعل
كثير من الامور وليس التطوير القدرات
الامنيه وحمايه
يعني حمايه السياده العراق عبر الدول
الاخرى هناك اليات اخرى سحب السلك
الدبلوماسي خلق السفارات غلق الحدود
المطارات هناك كثير من الامور يعني الان
ليس السلاح والسلاح العسكري فقط يمكنك
تستخدم السلاح السياسي والاقتصادي ايضا
انت تصدر نفسك الى تركيا الى ايران ايضا
تصدير واستراد يمكن توقفهم يعني حجم
التبادلات التجاريه التركيه العراقيه 20
مليار دولار في السنه يمكن توقف انت عارف
في المثل الذي يقول السكوت علامه الرضا
تفضل استاذ محمود
انا اريد ان يعني اشير الى الى مساله مهمه
طبعا دائما في النقاش الان يتحدثون
الزميلين المحترمين من بغداد وعندك في
الاستديو عن موضوع الخيرات العسكريه او
الخيرات السياسيه لدى بغداد للرد على
العمليات العسكريه التركيه والايرانيه لا
داعي ان التفكير بكل هذه المسارات هناك
مسار واحد مهم جدا الان هناك اجماع في
انقره وفي طهران وفي بغداد على ان حزب
العمال الكردستاني يشكل مشكله بالنسبه
لجميع البلدان انا اعتقد بانه الخيار
الامثل بالنسبه للجميع والاقل تكلفه على
بالنسبه لجميع الاطراف والتعاون في مساله
مكافحه حزب العمال كردستان حزب العمال
الكردستاني ليس فقط مشكله بالنسبه لتركيا
او ايران او للعراق ايضا هو المشكله
بالنسبه للاكراد ادخل المكون الكردي في
البلدان الثلاثه في صراع مع الحكومات
المركزيه في كل هذه الدول وفي العراق كان
هناك ايضا صراع قبل همم فتره ما بعد الغزو
الامريكي لذلك انا بانه همم من الضروري
الان الحديث بشكل منطق واقع في هذه
المساله تركيا اضطر الى العمليه العسكريه
لانها تريد ان تنتهي سياده العراق هناك
مشكله متمثله في حزب العمال الكردستاني
قبل الاسبوع فقط كان هناك اعتداء ارهابي
هنا في مدينه اسطنبول سيد الكريم وتركيا
اكدت من خلال الاعترافات الموجوده لدى
منفذه في الهجوم بان وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه مسؤوله عن هذا الاعتداء الحاله
الكرديه المسلحه في سوريا والعراق تشكل
خطر كبير على تركيا يجب على جميع الاطراف
ان تدرك هذه المساله نعم قد يكون هناك
دافع داخلي مرتبط اا مساله الانتخابات
ربما قد يكون هناك دافع مرتبط بمساله
الوضع الداخلي بايران بالاحتجاجات ربما
لكن علينا ان ندرك بانه هذا لا يشكل كامل
القرار في بيت استراتيجيه التركيه او
الايرانيه في سوريا والعراق هناك حاجه
امنيه بالنسبه للجانب التركي سابق ان دعت
انقره مرارا الى تعاون مع بغداد فيما
يتعلق بهذه المساله اعتقد بان الكره الان
في ملعب الجانب العراقي
الاسباب مشكله هتحسب العمال لكردستاني في
شمال العراق مشكله الارهاب هو ان الحكومه
المركزيه غير قادره على السيطره على كل
الاراضيها عندما ضعفت الحكومه المركزيه في
بغداد عندما ضعفت قدرت العراق على تامين
اراضيه بدا المخاطر تتعرض او تبرز وتنسحب
الى الدول الاخرى لعمليات العسكريه
التركيه وفق ميثاق الامم المتحده هي
عمليات مشروع لا يمكن لاحد ان التشكيك بها
على الاطلاق فالحقيقه لان هناك مخاطر هذه
الدول المناطق الحدوديه سواء في الجانب
التركي او في الجانب السوري ااا في الجانب
العراقي عفوا تشكل خطر بالنسبه للجانب
التركي لذلك يعني مع احترامي للزميلها
يمكن ان تتحدث كثيرا عن الخيرات يمكن ان
نتحدث كثيرا عن الانتهاكات التركيه
الانتهاكات الايرانيه لكن هذه النقطه لن
تؤدي بنا الى النتيجه
كان تحدث عن حل المشكله الحزب العمال
الكردستاني او يتفاق رباعي لانهاء حزب
العمال الكردستاني السؤال واحد لماذا ظهر
حزب العمال الكردستاني اولا ولماذا لي
الان مستمره لماذا
يدعمه بعض الدول او بعض الشخصيات او بعض
الجماهير او بعض القاعده الشعبيه يدعم
الحزب العمال الكردستاني
ينهي مشكله الاقليه الكرديه في تركيا لا
تركيا تركيا
بالمسؤوله عن تفجير اسطنبول عم ليه ارها
لا غبار عليه لكن لكن الناشط السوري
الناشط والطبيب والفنان السوري كمال
النبواني تحدث في عبر قناته في اليوتيوب
ونشرته الصحف التركيه ايضا قال ان احلام
بشير
هي ليست سوريه ولا يرتبط بجنسيه السوريه
عبر اتصالاته الخاصه من المخابرات
المعارضه ومن المخابرات النظام انها ليست
سوريه ولا ترتبط بالسوريه لان هذه عمليه
هنا مسرحيه مكشوفه ذكرنا فقط هي هي مش
سوريا المهم من هي لا نعلم بها السلطات
التركيه هو لازم يجيب عليها
صحيفه الزمان التركيه نشرت قبل سته ايام
ان احلام بشير اتصلت بشخص اخر في تركيا
عبر الرقم تليفون محمد تتحدث عن تفجير
اسطنبول
اتصل بالرقم كان باسم محمد امين الهان
امين حزب حركه القوميه في منطقه شراق
يعني برقمه الشخصي اتصل على الشخص الاخر
هذا الفتاه اللي تقول لنا سوريا دربت من
القبه الوحدات الشعب الكرديه ودخلت عبر
كوباني الى تركيا
كشفت هذه المدففه العمليه اقل من 24 ساعه
ولكن السؤال الاخر يواجه تركيا هذا الشخص
الاخر منذ 2016 هناك انقلاب حصل انقلاب ضد
الرئيس التركي ومن هو كالقائد المدمر
العقل الاول الى الاخر غير مكشوف طيب
المشكله المشكله التركي ليست حزب العمال
اترك الاستاذ محمود كذلك
محمود علوش
نعم مشكله تركيا هي حزب العمال الكردستاني
انا اريد ان ابدا بالتعقيب على الجمله
الاخيره لتفضل بها الضيف المحترف المشكله
التركي ليست مع المكونات
مكون كردي يعيش في تركيا لديه حقوق طبعا
كان في الماضي هناك قيود شديده انا اعتقد
انه خلال فتره حزب العداله والتنميه يعني
حصل تطور كبير فيما يتعلق بالمساله
الكرديه تم معالجه هذه المساله على نحو
كبير
والتاكيد على ذلك في عام 2013 عندما ابرمت
حكومه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اتفاق سلامه
حزب العمال الكردستاني ربما الضيف يذكر
جيدا هذه المساله لماذا نهار اتفاق
السلامه حزب العمال الكردستاني هذا سواء
المهم انهار اتفاق السلام مع حزب العمال
الكردستاني ببساطه لانه صعود المشروع
الانفصال الكردي في سوريا بتقديره والدعم
الامريكي لهذا المشروع الدعم الغربي لهذا
المشروع ادى الى افساد عمليه السلام بين
تركيا وحزب العمال والكرد الثاني مشهد
الان نتيجه انهيار عمليه السلام وكانت
عمليه السلام واعده بين تركيا وحزب العمال
الكردستاني لذلك المشكله واضحه لا اعتقد
بانه هناك في تركيا من ينظر الى الاكراد
كعلى انهم مشكله بالنسبه لي تركي هذا
هؤلاء لك لدم جزء من الشعب التركي هم جزء
لديهم حقوق وعليهم واجبات ولا اعتقد بان
هناك تمييز على الاطلاق ربما كان في
الماضي هناك تمييز نعم اعتقد اليوم الوضع
بالنسبه لكثير من الاكراد في في تركيا هم
يعيشون في وضع جيد لا باس به بالنسبه
للموضوع حزب العمال الكردستاني لا شك فيه
ما تفضل به الضيف انا اعتقد بانه صحيح
جزئيا على اعتبار انه حزب العمال يعني
يمثل جزء من الحاله الكرديه لكن لا يمثل
الحاله الكرديه علينا ان نكون واقعين
واعتقد بانه المكون الكردي في البلدان في
تركيا وفي سوريا وفي ايران او في العراق
علي يعني يدرك بانه مخاطر الحاله المسلحه
الحاله الانفصاليه المسلحه كانت على
القضيه الكرديه اكثر ما هي كانت مصلحه
للقضيه انظروا الان هناك مجموعه الدول
يعني تركيا رغم خلافاتها مع تركيا مع سوري
مع ايران رغم تنفسها مع ايران رغم خلافات
تركيا مع مع دمشق رغم خلافات تركيا مع
بغداد رغم كل ذلك الان تجمع كل هذه
الاطراف على انها لا يمكن ان تقبل باي حال
من الاحوال هذه الحاله الكرديه الانفصاليه
طيب عاد الينا من طهران الاستاذ سعيد
شاوردي استاذ سعيد السؤال الذي نريد يعني
جوابا عنه هو هل هناك تنسيق همم ايراني
تركي همم في التعامل مع هذه المناطق
الكرديه
تحيه طيبه لك استاذ عادل والضيوفك ولجميع
المشاهدين همم طبعا هناك مشكله يعني تعاني
منها دول يعني ايران وتركيا والعراق
وسوريا هي همم هذه الفصائل للاسف استخدم
يعني همم طرق ارهابيه اللي همم الحاقه
الضرر بمصالح هذه الدول الاربعه اعتقد نعم
هناك نوع من
التنسيق في ما بينها لمواجهه طبعا الارهاب
الذي ياتي من المنظمات التي تعمل مثلا في
اقليم كردستان العراق ولكن همم
برامج او خطط من هذه الدول تواجه تلك
المناظمات بشكل الانفرادي يعني مثلا حصل
همم استهداف لمقرات الاحزاب
الانفصاليه الكرديه التي تستقر في اقليم
كردستان العراق الليله الماضيه من قبل
استهدافها من قبل الحرس الثوري فيعتقد هذا
همم لم ياتي بتنسيق مع الدول الثلاثه
الاخرى ولكن طبعا هناك يعني زياره كانت لي
همم
الفريق همم اسماعيل همم يعني مؤخرا الى
العراق خلال
القاده العراقيين وقال لهم اننا همم نشعر
بخبر كبير خطر ارهابي ياتينا من اقليم
كردستان العراق همم هذه الخبر هو بسبب
تواجد همم منظمات انفصاليه او تدعوا الى
فصل عده ايرانيه ولا يمكن ان نقبل بهذا
الخطر ياتينا من الاقليم كردستان العراق
عن الحكومه المركزيه العراقيه ان تتصدى
الى هذه المنظمات التي هي دخلت بشكل غير
شرعي الى الاراضي العراقيه السياديه وهي
في الواقع بتحتاج تلك المناطق لانها ليست
منظمات عراقيه بل هي في الواقع عناصرها من
ايران فذهبوا الى هناك شك لهذه المنظمات
الارهابيه واليوم يستهدفون المدنيين
ويستهدفون الحدود الايرانيه ويتعاونون مع
جهات اجنبيه ل همم ان يقوموا بتفجيرات في
العديد من ايران ايران
تستهدف مثل هذه المنظمه معك ابقى معك
الاستاذ سعيد
همم
عندما تضرب ايران مواقع هي هي جغرافيه همم
مواقع عراقيه ولا يصدر عن الطرف العراقي
همم اي تحرك او تصريح قوي همم هل هذا يعني
ان ايران لديها همم ضمانات بانها تستطيع
ان تضرب ولن يتحرك شيء
طبعا السؤال عادل يعني نحن همم دائما لانه
حديث الزملاء سنعود سنعود اليك استاذ بسام
بغداد سنعود لان لان الضيف من طهران كانت
هناك مشكله تقنيه لم لم تنصفه في يعني في
هذا النقاش تفضل استاذ سعيد
وهي دائما يعني ليست فقط في الحكومه
الجديده بالحكومه السيد مصطفى الكاظمي
والحكومه التي كانت قبله كلها تؤكد انها
لا تريد ان تكون العراقيه العراقيه منطلقا
للاعتداء على اي بلد من دول الجوار ومن
ضمنها ايران فهذه النوايا الحسنه متواجد
لدى الحكومات المركزيه العراقيه سواء
الحاليه والحكومات التي سبقتها المشكله
للاسف تاتي بسبب عدم تعاون اقليم كردستان
العراق مع الحكومه المركزيه فهنا ايران
تنظر الى ان المشكله تاتي من السلطات في
اقليم كردستان فهي لا تبدي تلك الفرامه في
تعاملها مع هذه المنظمات التي تعيش هناك
وتتخذ من المناطق الجبليه مقرا لتواجدها
ولجلب السلاح تدريب العناصر الارهابيه
التي تعمل على ضرب المصالح الايرانيه
فاعتقد اليوم حتى الحكومه العراقيه يعني
ابدت همم ضوء اخضر او يعني خلال اللقاءات
الاخيره التي حصلت بين مسؤولين ايرانين
وعراقيين انه كل ما طلبنا نحن من السلطات
في اقليم كردستان العراق ان تمنع هذه
المنظمات للاسف لم يقوموا بمسؤولياتهم
فالمسؤوليه اعتقد اليوم وكما يقول هنا
المسؤولون في ايران تقع على السلطات
المحليه في اقليم كردستان العراق ونتمنى
انهم يعني يغيروا من سيادتهم التي انتهجها
خلال العقود الماليه
من بغداد
انا استغرب حقيقه في ان تركيا وايران يعني
يتكيان على موضوع البيكا كيف في شمال
العراق بالقيام بانتهاكات واضحه
بدليل ان هناك تدخل ايراني وتركي في جميع
المنطقه حتى وصل تدخل التركي الى قرابه
4000 كم في ليبيا وايضا جهز لذلك في تونس
وكذلك ايران وتدخلها الواضح في اليمن هذا
يعطي طباعا على ان طهران وانقره مفتونتان
بالتدخل وبصنع ربما مدن وشرعا عن ذلك
بربما ضاحيه في كل منطقه جغرافيه والعراق
على عكس ذلك كان ملتزم دائما بالقوانين
الدوليه ولم يوجه اسلحته اتجاه ايران
حينما كانت تحت ظل عناصر تنظيم القاعده
الذي يقوم بعمليات ارهابيه في الداخل
العراقي وكذلك لن يوجهه سلاح تجاه تركيا
التي تتواجد فيها عناصر
لعصابات داعش الارهابيه العراق سلكا
مسارات
الامنيه والتفاهمات الدوليه عبر استجلاب
عناصر مطلوبه بالتنسيق مع الجانب التركي
وايضا بالتنسيق مع حتى مع سوريا مع قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في العمليات الاخيره
هذه الامر يعطي انطباعا بان ايران وتركيا
تقذف
يقذفان الاتهامات عفوا اتفاقات عرض الحائط
وهما لا يحترمان سياده العراق الامر واضح
في ان تركيا الان تمتلك ما يناسب 40 معسكر
وقاعده ونقطه فيها عناصر تركيه في شمال
العراق وتحاول ايران الوصول الى هذه
المعادله في ربما في الايام المقبله
بذريعه محاربه البي كي كي نعم البي كي كي
يحتاج الى معالجات
صعبه جدا سبب انه لو قايسنا البي كي كيف
مع منظمه مجاهديه خلق التي كانت في العراق
كانت المنظمه في مكان واحد في العراق تم
التصويت في بذهن الحكم في العام 2003
باخراجها بالتنسيق مع الامم المتحده وتم
ذلك بالكامل في العام 2016 اي انه هنالك
قرابه العقد حتى استطاع العراق بالتنسيق
مع المجتمع الدولي باخراج منظمه تتواجد في
مكان واحد كيف الان يستطيع العراق اخراج
همم قرابه 600 قد تكون نقطه او اكثر همم
يسيطر عليها حزب العمال الكردستاني في
شمال العراق هذا يحتاج الى نعم الى تفاهم
اقليمي الى دعم الدولي لكن هذا لا يخلق
رائع لغرض التدخل وتجاوز الحدود من قبل ان
ترى طهران كلاهما يبحثان عن مصالح
والتصعيد التركي الواضح في القيام بعمليات
في العام الاخير هو دليل على رغبه اردوغان
في ان يصنع حاله من الراي العام في الداخل
التركي تجعله رئيسا لولايه الثالثه بعد
التعديل الدستور وكذلك ان طهران من باب
الاخر خاصه وان العمليات التي تقدم عليها
طهران تجري بازرع الحرس الثوري الايراني
اي ان هنالك راي للدوله العميقه في طهران
يدفع باتجاه
خلق راي عام ايضا في العراق هنالك من
يوالي الحرس الثوري في العراق ومؤثر في
القرار السياسي ولهذا اعتقد في ان الحكومه
العراقيه تحتاج الى اراده سياسيه بالكامل
تبدا بالبرلمان العراقي
بجميع قواه السياسيه حتى باقليم كردستان
لان اقليم كردستان يبحث عن خلق البيئه
امنيه ملائمه للاستثمار هنالك بيئه امنيه
هشه في شمال العراق بسبب تواجد لكي وسبب
التدخل الايراني والتركي ولا ننسى في
ايران تدفع باتجاه ضغط اقصى على اربيل
لغرض تفكيك الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
كما فككت حزب الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني
الذي اصبح الان ربما بثلاثه جبهات مختلفه
ورايين ذلك في القرار السياسي في داخل
السليمانيه وانعكسه على القرار السياسي في
بغداد هذا حقيقه لا يفرق من رغبه طهران
ورغبه انقره في قضم مناطق جغرافيه كما
استحولات على النظافه
العربيه
الجزء الشمالي الشرقي من المنطقه العربيه
التي تشكل ضاغطا على بقيه الدول وكذلك
تسعى طهران لخلق ممر ضغط ربما قريب من
اسرائيل هذه الامور جديده وواضحه جدا لا
يمكن الاختباء خلف الاصابع ولهذا
العراق نعم هو قد يمر بها ازمات سياسيه
بين فتره المؤخره تبطئ مشواره باتجاه
الضغط على ايران
فهمنا من كلامك ان ايران تستفيد من الضعف
همم السياسي
في العراق نعم نعم ترجمه ذلك الى مجلس
الامن عبره في القرارات
الوظائف الاداريه لحقيقه الحد من هذه
التدخلات او تسييجها كمرحله اولى وايقاف
التمدد الايراني
حزب العمال الكردستاني
[موسيقى]
كانه موجود في كل مكان كلما حدثت تمت ضربه
هنا او هناك الا وسماعنا حزب العمال
الكردستاني
كما هو كما تهمه العماله الاسرائيلي من
قبل الايراني
عملاء اسرائيلين معاقل اسرائيل وعاقل
الموساد في وقتها اسرائيل
ايران لا تفعل الشيء تركيا ايضا تركيا
تبحث عن مباره تبحث عن كبش الفداء ضيفي من
ضيفنا من اسطنبول يتحدث عن حقوق الاكراد
صحيح هناك حقوق الاكراد صلاح الدين
دمرتاشر الرئيس المشترك وعضو اللاعب في
برلمان
منذ 2016 في السجن كثير من الطرق كثير من
الرؤساء البلديات الذين فازوا في انتخابات
بلديه طريده هذه الديمقراطي وهذه الحريه
2018 وقف على النشاطات العسكريه
وقف نشاطات العسكريه لا في سوريا ولا في
تركيا ولا في ايران ولا في العراق اوقف
نشاطات العسكريه الحزب العمالي اصبح
الديكور اصبح اسم فقط مجرد اسم مجموعه من
مقاتلين موجودين في جبال القنديل ولا
تستطيع تطردهم
وكانت هذه خطه امريكا الولايات المتحده
بعد 2003 عندما احتلت العراق
طرحت مشروع طرد الحزب العمال الكردستاني
في جبل قنديل ولكن
نمنح الكلمه للاستاذ الاستاذ محمود علوش
من من اسطنبول
لديك تعليق ام ام تسمح لي بطرح سؤال
لا تفضل تفضل لانه يعني ظلمناك فيما يتعلق
بالاسئله ابدا ابدا ابدا انتم هنا انتم
يعني تحليل ياتي منكم انتم همم استاذ
محمود علوش قبل بضعي سنوات فقط كان الغرب
يتحدث عن خطر خطر تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
داعش حين ذاك كان المكون او العنصر الكردي
كانحب به يعني تعالوا يا اكراد سعيدون على
التخلص من هذا يعني من هذا الوحش ثم حتى
البشمركه من العراق
تمت يعني تم تم الاستعانه بهم همم والان
واليوم همم
من يعني من نسي او تخلى عن هؤلاء همم
الاكراد الغرب مارس النفاق معهم ماذا يحدث
يعني هو في الحقيقه هناك معضله برزت بشكل
واضح بعد الحرب على داعش في 2014 وهي انه
اييه وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه والبشمركه
في العراق كان يعني متصدرين للمواجهه ضد
داعش لا يمكن لاحد ان ينكر هذا الامل لكن
في خضم هذا الامر كان هناك توظيف واضح من
جانب المشروع الانفصال الكردي في سوريا
على وجه التحديد للحرب على داعش من اجل
السيطره على المزيد من الاراضي يا سيدي
هناك مناطق الان تسيطر عليها وحدات حمايه
الشعب الكرديه هي لم تكون موجوده فيها
اصلا وهناك تغيير ديموغرافي حصل في شمال
سوريا لا يمكن لاحد ان ينفي هذا الامر
وهناك حمله كانت منهجه من اجل وصل المناطق
سيطره وحدات الكرديه في غرب الفرات بشرق
الفراق وهناك مشروع لا يخفيه حتى الاداره
الذاتيه التي اعلن عنها اعلن عنها في خضار
من الحرب على داعش ما اعلنت الاداره
الذاتيه في شمال سوريا
بالنسبه لكثير من الاطراف بالنسبه انا
اعتقد انه في نهايه المطاف لا يمكن ان
اتحدث عن تخلي بالمطلق من جانب الدول
الغربيه عن الوحدات الكرديه لكن اعتقد لا
تستطيع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا
الدول الاوروبيه على وجهه تحديد ان تمضي
قدما في دعم الوحدات الكرديه بغض النظر عن
تداعيات العلاقه مع تركي شاهدنا الان كيف
ان فنلندا والسويد والاتحاد الاوروبي يسع
عموما الى استماره الموقف التركي فيما
يتعلق بالوحدات الكرديه فقط من اجل ان
تسمح تركيا لهتين الدولتين بالانضمام ايضا
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه رغم
الموقف المبدا الداعم للوحدات الكرديه
والتعاطف الامريكي مع المشروع الكردي
الانفصال في شمال سوريا لانه ايضا بدات
واشنطن خلال الفتره الاخيره تدرك مخاطر ان
تواصل هذه السياسه التصادميه مع تركيا
لانه في نهايتها في تركيا الان بدات تميل
الى روسيا في تعزيز الشركات مع روسيا في
المساله السوريه والاختار من ذلك بالنسبه
للمصالح الامريكيه والغربيه ان الان هناك
تحول في الموقف السياسي التركي نجد بان
تركيا مستعده بسبب مواجهه هذا الخطر
الانفصالي الكردي ان تفتح علاقت تعيد
علاقتها مع دمشق وبالتالي تخيل كيف حجم
الضرر سيكون على المصالح الامريكيه
والغربيه في سوريا على المدى البعيد انا
اعتقد بانه اذا ما كانت هناك قراءه واقعيه
ومنطقيه في الدول الغربيه للمصالح الغربيه
في سوريا فربما نشات تحول اكبر في الموقف
تجاه الوحدات الكرديه همم طهران الاستاذ
سعيد شاوردي ما ما ردك على من يقول ان
الوضع الداخلي همم في ايران هو الذي يدفع
همم بالحكام الى فتح جبهه خارجيه يعني
اللي لالهاء الراي الداخلي
طبعا استاذ عادل الكثيره ما نسمع مثل هذا
الكلام في هذه الايام ولكن لا اعتقد انه
صحيح يعني انت لو وقفنا انه اعترفنا ان
هناك مشكله داخل ايران بسبب اعمال الشقه
وهي طبعا مشكله لم تكن يعني ازمه هناك
عناصر ياتون يفعلون بعض الاعمال ولكن
ينتهون خلال ساعه ساعتين وينتهي كل شيء
ويروحون الى بيوتهم لو قلنا ان هذه مشكله
فانت عليك ان تركز طاقاتك لان هذه المشكله
هو الوصول الى حلول لانها هذه المشكله لا
ان تفتح يعني ازمه كبيره بمستوى حرب مع
همم سواء دول اقليميه او مع منظمات دوليه
مع مجلس الامه الامم المتحده لا اعتقد
يعني هذا من المنطقي ان تصنع لنفسك ازمات
خارجيه خارج بلادك وخارج حدودك ولكن
المشكله ان هذه منظمات الارهابيات تستقل
الاحداث حاليا في ايران عندما ترى ان هناك
يحصل اعمال شقق سواء في طهران او في
اصفهان او في مدن اخرى فتقول ان الفرصه
مهيئه لنا لكي نحن نمارس يعني اجراءاتنا
واعملنا التقليديه بما ان الحكومه تنشق
العناصر داخل ايران فلذلك يعني راينا او
كما سمعنا من الحكومه ومن الاجهزه الامنيه
هنا انه تم القاء القبض على عناصر متعدده
همم اكثر من 100 عنصر يعملون للمنظمات
الكرديه التي تتخذ مقر في اقليم كردستان
العراق اعترفوا انهم تدربوا هناك وايضا
تدربوا على يد عناصر من الموساد وحتى من
قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لتنفيذ
امنيه داخل ايران يعني قبل حوالي ثلاثه
اشهر القى القبض ااا خاليه ااا ارهابيات
كانت تخطط لاحداث تفجير كبير جدا في احد
الشركات المصنعه ليه الطائرات واللي همم
هي يعني لها علاقه بالمؤسسات العسكريه فلو
حدث هذا التفجير لكان يعني اودى بحياه 100
من الذين يعملون في تلك الشركه تم القاء
القبض عليهم كانوا عناصر من منظمات كرديه
يعمل تعمل في العراق واحترفه وبست
التلفزيون وبسمي الايراني هذه الاعترافات
واسمائهم وصورهم وكل شيء وهنا الكل يعرف
بهذه القضيه هناك اليوم انت لو تلاحظ بعض
القنوات
كرديه همم
تعلن يعني رسميا بشكل واضح انه نحن نريد
فصل هذه المحافظه وتلك المحافظه عن ايران
وان مؤسسه حكومه دوله كرديه همم وننتقل
نهائيا عن ايران طيب انتم مرفوضين من قبل
الشعب الايراني يعني اهل الكورد يعني انا
لا اتحدث عنهم هم حماه للحدود الغربيه
الايرانيه همم من الجهه الغربيه المحدده
للعراق يعني هؤلاء لا يريدون يعني كيف
يريدون ان تفصلوا هذه المناطق يعني والشعب
لا يوافق على هذا يعني الشعب الايراني كله
لا يمكن يسمع لكم بمثل هذه الاعمال مهما
استمرت يعني جرائمهم وقتلهم وهذه طبعا
ليست وليده اليوم تعود لاكثر من 40 عاما
لو تسمع فقط وكمل يعني كانت هذه المنظمات
هناك يعني منذ عشرات الاعوام يلقون القبض
على الجندي الذي يقف في الحدود ويذبحونه
وينشرون افلامه ويقولون كل جندي ياتي لهذه
المنطقه سوف نذبحها هذا معروف للشعب
الايراني يعني هذا مكتوب في التاريخ اليوم
يريدون الاستمرار بهذه السياسه سياسه
العنف والارهاب والتفجير والقتل والدعوه
الى فصل المحافظات عن ايران وبكل تاكيد
يعني اجزم واقول لك ان هذا لن يحدث وايران
ستتعامل معهم بصرامه اذا استمروا على هذه
السياسه نحن نعتب يعني على الاخ فقط لو
تسمح لي واكمل هذه النقطه من
العزيزه نعم نحن والله حريصون على امنكم
اصطياد العراقيه ونعتبرها سياده وامننا
ولكن انت عندما تقول انا لا استطيع افعل
شيئا مع هذه المنظمات فهل من المعقول ان
نسمح لها بارتكاب جرائمها ضد مواطنين في
البلد لا يمكن يعني
الدخول سعيد
يعني هل مقبول ان نقبل بان هذه الناصر
تذهب الى تلك المناطق وتفجر هنا في ايران
وتلجا هناك وانت لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيئا
هل هذا مقبولا
من بغداد
وفق المسارات والتفاهمات هنالك غرفه
رباعيه
تدرس الامن المشترك في المنطقه انتم عضو
فيها لا ان تذهبوا بشكل منفرد او بسياسه
العزل اين هنالك تفاهمات امنيه في مقابل
ذلك هنالك تدخل صارخ في بانتهاك اسياد
العراقيه عليكم ان تقدموا الادله للحكومه
العراقيه في ان هنالك عناصر من داخل
الاراضي العراقيه تتجاوز الحدود وتمضي
باتجاه خلق ربما عمليات او تستهدف ربما
التحتيه الايرانيه لكنها هنالك حقيقه رائع
وهي قد تكون هنالك ايضا تخيلات او تكون
هناك حاله من خلق بعض الذراع التي تبحث
عنها طهران وكذلك ان ترى كلاكما تذهبان
باتجاه صنع سياسه خارجيه توعدان من خلالها
حصول على اوراق اعتماد للمجتمع الدولي
لغرض التفاوض على ملفات اخرى في مقابل ذلك
العراق الان حتى اللحظه هو الاكثر التزاما
او الوحيد من هذه المعادله ملتزم بالاعراف
والقوانين الدوليه ملتزم بالدستور العراقي
يستطيع العراق ربما القيام بعمليات
مشابهه او قريبه من تلك العمليات لكن هو
حتى اللحظه يلتزم بالامم المتحده
بقراراتها واعتقد في ان هذا سيضيف نقاط
ايجابيه للعراق وايضا يمكن له ان يمضي
بسياسه العزل التي تمضي بها انقرى وطهران
وهي ان تكون هناك تفاهمات اقتصاديه وامنيه
مشتركه وتستمر في ملفات اخرى لكن سيذهب
باتجاه ربما انشاء عقوبات
على ايران وتركيا في ما هي التدخل
حول محاولتهما بتحضير الاداريه
المخصص ما اعاده تنفيذ الشتاء الواضحه
شكرا لك الاستاذ بسام القزويني من بغداد
اشكر الاستاذ محمود علوش من اسطنبول اشكر
كذلك الاستاذ سعيد شاوردي من طهران ولك
الشكر كذلك استاذ كرزان حميد كنت معنا هنا
في الاستديو من باريس مشاهدينا الاعزاء
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]